Sorry. Here are my disclosures. Primary CNS lymphoma is a rare disease, making up less than
1% of all non-Hodgkin lymphoma, and it's a disease of elderly. Median age of diagnosis is mid-60s to
late-60s, and incidence increases sharply with age. It goes from 0.4 to 4 per 100,000 in patients
over 70 years old. More than 40% of patients are over 70, and more than 20% of patients are
over 80. And age is considered an independent poor prognostic factor in primary CNS lymphoma.
The standard of care treatment right now is to give high-dose methotrexate induction followed
by transplant. But as I said, a lot of patients that present with primary CNS lymphoma are older
patients, and they are often transplant ineligible. And right now, there's no standard of care for
transplant ineligible patients. And the consolidation and maintenance approaches that we've been using
are very heterogeneous.
And the real-world outcomes are very poorly characterized.
So I conducted a multi-center retrospective study from 12 academic U.S. centers from 2010 to 2024.
The use of induction therapy was at physician's discretion. The patients that were involved in
the studies were over 18 years old. We limited the study to diffuse large B-cell lymphoma subtype.
They had to have been treated with high-dose methotrexate induction or variation of,
and they must have had a stable disease,
or better, post-induction prior to receiving consolidation or maintenance.
They were deemed transplant ineligible by the treating physicians, and the primary
outcome endpoint was PFS and looking at different consolidation and maintenance approaches.
Total, 191 patients were included. Median age was 69. About 40% of patients were ECOG2 or higher
with presence of geriatric syndromes. Majority of patients had either motor or cognitive changes.
Here's a breakdown of the induction regimen that was used. A third of a patient received MTR,
methotrexate, temozolomide, rituximab. A third received the MPVR, methotrexate,
procarbazine, vincresine with rituximab. And a third received methotrexate only or with rituximab.
Here's a breakdown of why they were transplant ineligible. A fifth of patients for functional
status. A fifth for age, about 15% for both. A fifth was unknown. And then 15% for both.
And then 15% for preference and small percentage for lack of support.
Here are the consolidations and maintenances that were used for consolidation. Majority of the
regimens were cytarabine-based, either alone or with combination, with etoposide being the most
common regimen that was used with cytarabine. Radiation was another one that was frequently
used. Maintenance was a little bit more broad. There were patients that were treated with
rituximab or high-dose methotrexate. And then there were patients that were treated with
temozolomide, BTK inhibitor, lenalidomide, or some combination thereof. There was a strong
institutional preference for consolidation or maintenance strategies, indicating that there
isn't really a good standard of care, and that physicians are relying on their past experience.
About three-quarters of patients completed intended post-induction therapy.
So here is a treatment outcome of all comers, and so everybody that's been treated. PFS was 69 months
and OS was 12 months. So here's a treatment outcome of all comers, and so everybody that's been
treated. PFS was 69 months and OS was 123 months. The first look at this data, I was actually quite
surprised because this was actually much better than I had intended for transplant-ineligible
patients. The induction regimen really made no difference in PFS and OS, although I'm not showing
the data here. Not surprising, but you did see a worse overall survival benefit with lack of CR.
So on the left, you see that if you have complete response, you tend to do much better. And if you
had a poor performance status at diagnosis, so if you had the ECOG of one, you did much better than
if you had the ECOG of two or worse. The PFS and OS were very similar between all consolidation
therapies. You can see the blue is etoposide with cytarabine. The red is cytarabine and other
combinations. And then green is radiation. You see that all the lines overlap. The PFS was 62 months
and OS was 95 months. And all the consolidation approaches had similar outcome. And this was the
same for maintenance therapies. There are several maintenance therapies that we've looked at.
There were really no differences in their PFS and OS. The PFS with the maintenance approach was
78 months with OS was not reached. But if you look at all the PFS and OS between the
consolidation and maintenance, there really wasn't any differences. What we do know, however,
is that the PFS and OS were very similar. The PFS and OS were very similar. The PFS and OS were
OS is very short in patients who progress.
So about a third of patients relapse or progress, and overall survival after progression was
only 10 months compared to 123 months that we saw in the entire cohort.
About 20% of patients were hospitalized, and not surprisingly, the hospitalization was
higher in patients who got maintenance because you were receiving therapy for a much longer
period of time, and majority of these were infections and febrile neutropedia.
So in conclusion, we see that treatments are very heterogeneous and that it is highly institutional
dependent.
There are excellent outcomes even for transplant-ineligible patients with median overall survival over
120 months, and that overall survival was significantly associated with performance
status and depth of response after induction.
And what induction you used really did not influence the overall survival.
There was no significant difference between PFS and OS, between consolidation and maintenance
approaches, even if you adjusted for age, sex, ECOG, and response.
The real major unmet need are the people that progress.
So about a third of patients relapse and progress, and they really had a poor outcome with a
short overall survival of 10 months.
Given that there is really no significant difference between regimens, I think the take-home
point from here is that really we should be deciding on the patient's consolidation or
maintenance regimen based on safety profile.
With that, these are my acknowledgments, and a lot of the collaborators, Adam did a whole
bunch of statistics for us.
Thank you.